alright I'm on with Gian Marco in
Switzerland how's it going on in
Switzerland right now hey it's good it's
evening and yeah I just waiting for your
call here yeah I got a guy with better
hair than me this is very upsetting but
we're gonna we're gonna do it anyway
alright so one of the things you wanted
to talk about was sort of coming out as
an atheist which i think is really
interesting and it's one of the things
we've talked about here that people feel
this need to make this proclamation so
can you tell me a little bit about your
journey yeah sure
well I was born and raised in
Switzerland so it's not a dead religious
country it's just like yeah I had some
some religion classes in primary and
stuff but I was never really religious
yeah Catholic was a Catholic classes no
it was evangelical okay and yeah then I
went to Sydney for a fur exchange
semester when I was like 18 19 and I
stumbled upon this this debate of Ken
Ham against 9 yeah yeah so and I was
like to say the least thought it was
ridiculous that that some people would
think that way like Ken Hemi would so
basically for people that don't know
he's the he's the guy that runs the what
at the biblical park somewhere in
America and he debated Bill Nye about
evolution verse creation yeah yeah
exactly yeah so I was like a bit yeah
confused and and yeah I told my brother
and he was a little bit more into that
and he showed me Christopher Hitchens
and Richard Dawkins and I thought it
would be good English lesson to you to
read those those books like God is not
great and so yeah
I thought that I was always talking to
some people there because I had like
connections to everywhere in the world
because like I had some people from from
Chile there from Switzerland from
Belgium from everywhere so what the stun
me the most was this guy from
Switzerland actually who was like well I
believe in creationism and I was like
just it was a Swiss guy like me right
what was thinking that that like Noah's
Ark really happened right was just it
was just mind-blowing for me so I
started to watch debates on YouTube and
stuff and yeah when I came home I I was
late
full-blown 80s yeah and it it sounds to
me that you deal with exactly what most
atheists deal with which is that it's
not actually that big of a deal but you
feel like you have to sort of say it
because otherwise the world just thinks
you believe something that you don't
Yeah right right
it's like that and like when I when I
discover is all of this I was I was a
little bit more militant I don't know
how to say like sure I have thought
people who believe this stuff are stupid
or not really stupid but like ignorant
and then it's kind of weird so I got a
little bit out of that I let them have
their beliefs whatever yeah but I need I
feel need to tell that I don't believe
that yeah yeah well it's funny cuz I
always say it's like to me I don't care
what you believe as long as you're not
trying to chop my head off or making me
believe anything else then you book you
go ahead believe whatever you are you
know yeah alright so one of the things
that you wrote in that you want to talk
about that I thought was really
interesting was that you want to talk
about the difference between the US
Constitution and the Swiss Constitution
and that basically you think that we're
don't worry about the hair that was that
we that we are sort of obsessed with
never changing our Constitution but you
guys actually change your Constitution
pretty frequently right yeah it was it
was like
is all debate about gun regulation and
the Second Amendment United States and I
thought to myself like why wouldn't they
allow to change that like it did beside
all this lobbying and and stuff from yet
arrived I have a reading Gallup poll
they're like fifty five percent of the
American people are for a more strict
coming regulation so and I looked into
it a little bit more and what I found
was was pretty astonishing to me I've
always thought like the American
Constitution is kinda is kinda static
and just for two hundred and thirty
years it was over almost the same and
Swiss Constitution as you may know we
have referendums like four times a year
where people just send in some ideas and
we voted on it right and this is like
changing the constitution every time
wait did you say you guys do that four
times a year yeah man that's a lot and
people show up and vote four times a
year and actually change the
Constitution that often yeah yeah it's
like well we have we have like like
fifty fifty-five percent of the people
vote the rest is just like yeah well do
whatever you want yeah and yeah but we
won't like for 12 or well 12 to 15
different referenda each year huh in
poor thanks yeah so all right so have
you seen any gimme give me like one good
example of that like something that you
guys have changed for the better and one
time that maybe it didn't work if you
can think of something
yeah sure we had 2010 I think it was
like the the far-right party of of
Switzerland a SVP
proposed that we should ban minarets
like the towers on the mosques of the
yeah so and it was accepted by the
people so now we have in our country
with an article like 72 that it's
prohibited to build minarets like we
have like to build it was like no issue
at all
right so it wasn't really a problem but
the far-right grabbed it yeah yeah I was
just like obeah and populistic and yeah
and a good thing we accept it I really
need to think about that it's like it's
like most things are good that they're
not accepted right like we have some
some like all these proposals are either
far right or far left
mm-hmm yeah like minimum wages and I
mean that's kind of okay but minimum
wages were like set to $22 per hour
and that's just ridiculously high I mean
who will pay that right so does that
ultimately hurt the Swiss economy I mean
the businesses then leave Switzerland
because it sounds like Switzerland we
always think of it as though they have
so much money everybody's so happy it's
so great yeah from what I've heard and
what I bred I think it would really hurt
the country as a financial hotspot and
then yeah yeah yeah so the other thing
that you wanted to talk about which is
one of the things that almost everyone
in Europe especially has wanted to talk
to me about is the refugee situation and
political correctness so I'll let you go
from there yes so refugee crisis in
Switzerland itself I mean I'm not that
fond of like like the whole European
situation I know where crews are closed
on Belkin root and stuff don't worry I'm
not gonna quiz you on everything we're
just we're just getting your opinion
okay okay
so yeah I'm basically for like letting
refugees thing like I mean we're all
humans we should we should get along
with each other and help each other
that's like human hair you
many herring aspect of it but like the
left is is pushing like these these
ideas or these reasons to let them in
like for example when when someone says
just like something a little bit I don't
know let's say controversial about
refugees and and yeah and what they're
doing it's just like shouted down and
and then you you cannot talk probably
about about what the issue is with the
refugees that come in I mean I'm all for
letting them in but we have to talk
about the issues that are coming to us
with this yeah I yeah they're just like
like saying that or yeah saying no there
are no problems at all coming with this
or like yeah maybe a little bit
financial but nothing really
cultural or yeah yeah just listen that
that's exactly why I'm talking about
around the show cuz we got to have these
conversations listen well that was quick
but it was a pleasure talking to you and
thank you all right I'm on with Adam in
Sweden Adam how's it going it's going
just fine actually
great reporter to this cool well me too
so you know I've mentioned a lot about
Sweden and just recently I had Tino San
and dodgy on the show who's an economist
from Sweden and one of the few people
that will talk about the political
correct situation and sort of this
regressive ideology that seems to have
taken hold in Sweden and I got a lot of
messages from Sweden talking about that
and you were the one we went with so we
expect you to represent your your whole
country here we go oh boy I'm the most
swedish sweetie you just could find so I
will not really good representation
there well as you know I believe that
it's about the individual not about the
the bigger group so let's start with
that so one of the things you wanted to
talk about was that the political
correct this seeping ideology and what
it's doing to society in Sweden so let's
start with that
well I've been doing a lot of thinking
to actually explain this because it's
it's very hard really since you need so
much context for it and we have so
little time for yes just say that goes
back at least a hundred years started
with the socialism and everything like
that in Sweden but in the modern era at
least since the 70s Sweden was a hotbed
for very radical left ISM in the 70s we
even had left this terrorist and
everything like that
in Sweden that occupied and the West
German and it's got West German embassy
so it has a long tradition but the
biggest things I actually want to
explain with this that explains how
Sweden works today it's two terms and I
think of it translated them recently one
is called the opinion corridor and I
think that's kind of self-explanatory
but I'll give it that is in Sweden
there's a very narrow corridor of
opinions you're allowed to have it
arrest well if you have only opinion
outside of that like me it you're a Nazi
or a racist or bigoted and you know
you're all of that now just to be clear
you're not a Nazi or a racist or a bigot
let's just get that out there I may be
very Aryan but I'm not a Nazi and that
opinion corridor for my entire lifetime
has just been narrowing and and I would
definitely say that it narrowed its most
when Obama became a president really
yeah I would say Sweden the last I say
two decades I guess has tried to emulate
America in all its worst parts so we
always had this opinion corridor but
then we saw how you just guy started
going with the political correctness
part and then it just went worse
so yeah I think that explains that part
and then we also have another term that
we didn't advance but a Swedish
political commentator in the 70s put to
coin very well
he's called Wilhelm amou Barre and I
would recommend reading up about him
because he will give a lot of context to
the [ __ ] that's going on today and I
think I'll try to transfer site demo
creatorship he called it mhm combination
of the word democracy and dictatorship
right
and that works essentially in that we
have a formal democracy and but on the
best of the of the cultural force that
our government represents and we have an
enforced dictatorship of a sort in the
form of the cultural hegemony in Sweden
that at least you know has its
expression in the in the opinion
corridor right so what you're talking
about basically is as we use this phrase
the oppression Olympics you guys are
really big on this that depending on who
you are and where you're from and your
religion and your skin colour we really
put you in this pecking order right
absolutely and you basically you were
very much a homogeneous society and now
that's really changing so the pecking
order starts getting even we were a very
homogenous society up until at least the
90s mmm-hmm that's when the Balkan wars
erupted and we had the genocide and
everything that and we got a lot of
refugees from that they've integrated
mostly well we didn't really get to
problems until we have the very large
immigration from the Middle East
it's easier to integrate a European
culture than a completely foreign
culture from an entire different
portrait or different cultural context
and all of that but we've been saying
that would label you a racist right
absolutely I'm definitely a racist for
saying that so the problem is because
that's outside the pinyon corridor we
can talk openly about it
and that's caused all a lot of issues
and yeah so that leads that leads
directly to the other thing that you
want is talk about especially
exactly I mean yeah it leads to the
other thing you want to talk about which
is the rise of the right in Sweden which
is a new phenomenon so can you lay that
out yeah it's a new phenomenon because
in Sweden the left has essentially ruled
since post-world War two for 60 years we
had one-party dominant in in our what's
it called and Parliament for 60 years we
have the Social Democrats completely
dominant in the parliament only one
interruption for four years and that's
kind of when I look about you I'm a
student of history so I can see the
negative side of it's absolutely insane
does he just have one party sure they
did achieve some pretty good things the
things we call fall commit in Sweden our
welfare states they did achieve that but
they also dismantled it so but the right
has risen because we can't speak about
these things and they are the only ones
that have the balls to speak about it
because well the extreme part were
already Nazis the less extreme part
didn't really care to be compared that
they were compared with the Nazis so
they just talked about it and now the
only way to talked about this is to
dedicate yourself to being on the
far-right essentially yes so we see this
happening in America right now and
that's why I've been talking about it
because I see all of you guys not just
in Sweden but all over Europe I see this
happening and I'm trying to help that
not happen here so what does that do for
a person like you a person that is not a
Nazi and is not a racist and yet you see
a problem with society and only one
group talking about it weird where does
that leave you completely alone
essentially because the left well they
think I'm the Great Satan they're right
well I'm also the Great Satan for then
because well you know I kind of think
that brown people or people too and job
them like people and that's not right
according to their before right yeah I
mean I consider myself
ideologically ideologically independent
because I consider ideologies to be
secular religions so I shy away from
those things so it's very hard being of
my camp in
which is you know liberal essentially
yeah well you know what that's that's
the whole purpose of this show and
almost everyone that I'm talking today
talking with today over all over the
world I mean this is what it's all about
so I just to end this real quick though
because we got to go you're starting
your own YouTube channel right to get
these ideas across so where can we send
people the YouTube channel has been slow
on the uptake because I have been busy
I'm a college student so and but look
for the thought criminal's channel in on
your future all right I'm on with
Michael in Colorado Michael how are you
hi Dave I'm good good to see you yeah
good to see you so I have to tell you we
picked 20 people at a 1200 and I hope
you take this the right way you are the
elder statesman of the group oh boy yeah
not to add any extra pressure okay well
that'll give me a beer at the local bar
so that's good absolutely so first off
you had a really interesting history
that's one of the reasons why I wanted
to talk to you and you were in the Navy
so first off tell me when you served and
where you served I was in the Navy I
joined and when I was 18 out of high
school went in in 1961 put that in
context let's see President Kennedy
announced the Apollo program West Side
Story came out and our President Barack
Obama was born when he was in diapers I
was in boot camp and I served eight
years got out in 1969 to go to college
San Diego I was on a guided missile
destroyer all over the Pacific for a
while came back got involved in the
Polaris submarine program and I was
stationed in Spain for a couple of years
and in a Charleston for a couple of
years working on some high tech you know
secret stuff and said I do stew that and
what's school on the GI Bill took a
degree in anthropology and pretty much
minored in history and you know the life
going on when you look back at that part
of your life the service part of your
life do you do you think of it fondly do
you do you miss it anything like that I
do think of it finally you know distance
you know mate does make the mind grow a
little bit more you know accommodating I
think but all it was really good for me
I had no idea what I want
to do when I was 18 years old my friends
many of them were going off to college
but I knew I wasn't really ready for
that somehow it was good for me in a lot
of ways you know it helped me to grow up
he gave me some responsibilities let me
know that I can handle that gave me the
equivalent of a master's degree in
electrical engineering which was a big
help but when I got out I abandoned
engineering and went directly into
anthropology because eight years of
engineering is pretty is enough but I'm
pretty sure if my notes served me
correct that in 1964 before you went to
anthropology you built a computer well a
built and more more to the point I
programmed my first digital computer
because when I got in the the Polaris
program that all the systems on the
boats these are intercontinental
ballistic missile systems or run by
computers in 1964 those computers were
probably not quite as powerful as the
iPhone but I was very fascinated with
computer still still AM and as part of
my training we put together a little
block system of computers of a digital
computer and learn how to do the basic
programming it was all what we call
machine language it was all ones and
zeroes we went to the lab and we started
programming and working on the big guys
at 1964 so that was my introduction to
digital computers yes oh that's so cool
so 1964 you're working on the very
beginnings of of digital computers and
he said all zeros and ones did you ever
do remember ever having the glimpse of
what that could become did you ever
think you could be walking around with
this thing in your pocket that would be
exponentially more powerful than
everything you were working on at the
moment I don't think anybody did at the
time you know because it was the
beginning of solid state to solid state
years these things are really big they
were they were in cabinets did the soap
and et cetera
I remember the personal computer the
Altair those those came out you know it
was pretty neat you could have one at
home but hell you know digital or le LCD
watches were the big thing back then and
in Texas Instrument calculators nobody
really thought that we'd be able to have
an
phone and communicate face-to-face Dick
Tracy liked things when I was growing
out the comics we you know we thought
that would be pretty cool but whoever
thought that the advances would be that
fast yeah well I remember being at a
friend's house probably when I was six
on a Texas Instruments computer playing
they had their own version of pac-man it
was like they're ripped off version of
pac-man I thought it was the coolest
thing ever
yeah yeah well you know there was a book
called future shock you're probably
familiar with years ago in which Alvin
Toffler predicted that progress would be
so fast that by the time you began to
get a little bit comfortable the next
thing will come along and you'd be a
little bit in shock and your deal with
that the next thing we're coming the
next thing would come but I think that's
pretty much where we're at right now it
does seem like that that the second we
get okay with a little bit of the
technology or just as some another app
comes out the second you're okay with
one and now this one does something else
and you forget that it's really it's
fascinating it is and you know what I
find kind of disheartening is a lot of
people one of the things I do here is I
have oh the library board if I help some
of the older retirees here try to deal
with their iPads and their iPhones and
God help them their Windows computers
etcetera that must be a trial in
patience it's tough can you deal can I
give you much can I give my mom your
number you can okay good
not a problem but you know I think a lot
of the older people are now
understanding that this is actually a
device that can be used for things like
we're doing here and for making contact
with other people and spreading ideas
and getting your ideas out so as they
become easier to use you know human
sense people are gonna look past the
technology now I have a neighbor is
she's 20 years older than me all right
so she's 93 years old she has an iPad as
her her email and her here little Google
things and all that with her iPad and
she's quite quite familiar with it it's
sort of magic to her but she knows how
to use it so it puts her in touch that's
really that's pretty cool all right
let's shift topics all together because
you gave me a bunch in the submission
you you are an atheist were you always
an atheist when did you decide you were
an atheist where you were an atheist
before it was cool now it's cool
yeah well some places they're still not
cool I can point you to write down we
have five churches and for real estate
offices on a town of 800 so think about
that black ribbon so you're a real
minority you're a minority in a minority
right there yeah yeah I am especially
here I remember I was thinking about
that and I remember when I was probably
five or six we were living with my
grandmother going to church Sunday
mornings Sunday night Wednesday night
Methodist Church lo North Texas town
sitting at Sunday school looking out the
window at the treaty and the swing and
so I'm thinking god I'd rather be
anyplace better I think probably real it
realistically about the time I figured
out Santa wasn't real I had the same
kind of questions about the stories I'd
been I've been taught so for about as
long as I can remember I guess yeah so
one of the other things you mentioned is
that you're you're sort of fascinated by
how Christians and and just religious
people in general are often deceived by
their sources so it's not even
necessarily the source itself right it's
not necessarily the book itself but it's
sort of the messengers that are the
deceivers am I getting what you said
sort of correctly I think it's both
those things um you know if you look at
Abrahamic religions today they don't
have what we consider to be basic hard
core evidence for their claims the only
thing they have for a source or books
that's the amount of oral traditions
it's the amount of ancient manuscripts
that have been copied and recopied and
copied and changed and different so I
think it there's a problem because the
people who are their pastors and who are
their priests and go to Divinity School
they understand the history of their
religion they know the questions
involved they know the contradictions
they know that a lot of this is really
false but they don't tell that to their
congregations so the people who hear
this really have no independent way of
judging whether this is real or not so
you know if I have a book somebody's
giving me a book and says look this is
reality
I have some questions well where it come
from what does it say how do we know
what it says is true
etc so digging back into those sources
and being able to come up with what we
think are historically realistic stories
about all this helps people to be a
little bit more critical and judge the
things that they did take on faith yeah
so one of the things when I've talked to
other atheists and when I talk about
atheism in general one of the questions
I get is people say well how do you have
a moral Center then how are you able to
have a hold that you live by without
religion I think you're laughs already
sort of gave away your answer but tell
me how have you how what have you based
your moral Center on what do i base my
moral Center on well like I tell you
know we have two adopted kids they're
they're adults these days and they're
doing quite well and one of the reasons
that they're doing well is because they
know what's right and what's not right
you have this I think humans have this
inherent ability to to understand that
the right way to act for example it's
the way you act when nobody is watching
you you come out of this feeling of
compassion for other people you come out
of this feeling of being able to help
other people and to be basically a good
person I mean sociopaths aside normally
constructed human being you know I feel
that you understand this I mean the
Greeks understood that the Romans
understood it the Plains Indians
understood it right they they were all
allied to different religious systems so
it's not an a it's not something out of
a religious tradition or a book that
says follow these rules I mean you know
it's wrong if you kill somebody
murder for example that's just human
basic wrong and I don't think it takes
an ancient book and in dictates from the
guy in the sky to say you know do this
and you're in trouble yeah and if it
does there's probably a bigger problem
there's a bigger problem there's a
bigger problem all right so
unfortunately have to wrap it up but let
people know so you're working on a book
correct and you have a website so where
where can we send people you can send
people I have a book it's already I self
published in this out on Amazon the key
fragments and it's about to say it's
about basically what we've been talking
about great it's digging back into the
sources into finding out how in a
secular situation what happened is the
novel characters in action you can go to
the cue fragments calm it's out there
links are out there I cast it every
chapter as a podcast that I read so I
just like people to read it
enjoy the tale and think about the
message that underlies this write that
all of these myths and everything may
have come from some particular
historical actors of people but they're
not necessarily what people are trying
to get us to believe today yeah well I
love that message and I love chatting
with you so thank you so much appreciate
it all right thank you have a great
night and thank you for your program all
right I'm on with Brendan and Ireland
Brendan how's it going anything like I'm
doing well I feel like you could be my
Irish cousin we are dressed exactly the
same yeah apparently actually my
brother-in-law is half Irish and his
name is Brendan so there you go okay I
probably should know that I'm gonna have
to get back to you I know you already
got me in trouble I think he's from near
the local pub alright so what's going on
these days in Ireland we don't hear much
about Ireland in the news how's it going
over there
we're pretty small so you won't hear
much about us but uh quite at the moment
we just had a new government formed and
ten weeks after her election
miraculously no fan there's there's a
lot of discussion kind of and we have
we'd water charities were brought in and
that's kind of been discussed a lot and
the the fire laughs does in the
socialist parties they're not very happy
with it neither are not neither anybody
really apart from the parties and
government and there's discussion over
with being our 8th amendment which is
basically it's it's a stipulate stuff
abortions leaving on
and obviously in the legal front we last
year we legalized marriage for
homosexuals
which is fantastic I wasn't in the
country I was actually abroad and sure
enough for the year and you know if
you're Irish abroad which I wasn't too
happy I couldn't go I mean that would be
pretty yeah wait wait let's pause there
for a second so that's really
interesting so you guys voted for
legalizing gay marriage which is
obviously very great and a very liberal
progressive concept and then at the same
time you're telling me that they're
voting on possibly repealing a law that
would allow abortion no no its repeal
the law that oh so abortion is boys
abortion completely illegal yeah Wow so
I do prev I assume people are having
illegal abortions because people have
them whether it's not or not right
generally handing over things oh wow so
he owned a lot so do you think the law
is gonna pass I would say so I mean
there was a safety deck last year there
was FC fervent and opposition from
perhaps the churches and still against
the gangs being large I mean are they
losing their power quickly how much
power do they actually hold over
politics these days they're you know
they're kind of I mean like you don't
get too many people on timaeus and they
don't take you much of it seriously and
most of Ireland is very you know regards
to say homosexuality or whatever we're
generally as a country or Jannetty quite
alright with it we're quite a country
basically like as the only thing you
don't annoy me I don't really care what
you do you know what I mean that's my
personal ideology - yeah I need to go to
Ireland obviously so you're studying
politics right yeah yeah what got you
interested in politics tell me do you
remember I think I just really wanted a
I can I'll make it maybe it's probably
the Alabamians animation that's all
you know just starving African children
and still from you wanted to be like God
I'd love to help someone like that I'm
just kind of green guerrillas very
interested in war and I did a predator
module a semester which is ethnic
conflict respond tasks that looks for
your masters in in in a complex
mathematical problem yeah
so it's I'd love to work in the United
Nations in my thought and a conflict
resolution I'm actually I'm my to final
exam for my whole undergraduate our
cheapest beginning so I'll be doing I'm
sorry
nice nice well thanks for taking some
time then so so one of the things that
you wanted to talk to me about is one of
the things that pretty much everybody
wanted to talk about which is political
correctness and now it's how it's
seeping into society so what's going on
on that front in Ireland um I think I
think a lot of the stuff you see in I
think ideas of racism and stuff I
reported from America we all think only
from the race and when America is a very
specific problem with races you know
what I mean
and we think oh my god you're racist
towards black people about we never had
that hope because you know we don't even
our own country for like e94 years many
five years right well you'll get your
guess people it's generally tired less
people people in the on the social
spectrum I'm not saying you don't have
to be a socialist obviously to be you
know ridiculously no I imagine you I was
saying you know regressive laughing off
then you get that we had that to do the
German group together of course you know
yeah yeah they had a protest here so
it's not really picking up steam there
well this particular incident they were
chased down the street by a by a counter
protesters to which we were like I think
I I thought these agree with a brief
that raises their fascist whatever but
me nothing's everyone to say and I put
them in a row behind themselves but I
think in art and we're doing okay and
when you look we see stuff we're having
in America
you [ __ ] vouch for everything that's
going on here I'm wondering about some
of it myself
don't worry I think we're okay and what
I mean when it comes to
- terrorist attacks and criticizing
Islam you did get some greedy who a lot
not as I'm sorry is the use of Islam in
a violent way use of anything when I
mentioned that on the clouds and they
got some pretty when he looks yeah
that's been one of the through lines
here because we're just talking about
ideas and you mentioned an idea and you
get some funny looks in class yeah but
no no one is a known as shutting me down
it's but a safe space which is progress
so you don't know you guys don't have
safe space is there a trigger warnings
no with you smiled looking smaller that
you are University they're too small and
I don't know hasn't caught on yet I
think if the combo maybe of small
universities and a lot of beer would
that be fair to say before there you go
well listen it was it was a pleasure
talking to you and if you have any other
fashion recommendations let me know
alright I am on with Briana in Japan
Brianna how are you how are you I'm
doing well so according to my notes here
you are in Japan via Tennessee how many
people can say that
why not very many so from personal
experience they probably don't even know
Tennessee is here ninety nine percent
I am so yeah so tell me not imagine tell
me a little bit about that so do you
grew up in Tennessee and when did you
move to Japan what are you doing there
what's going on yes so I grew up in
Tennessee I was there for 18 years of my
life until I moved to Philadelphia for
college and I've been in Japan for the
past six months now or study abroad I'll
be here a bit longer and in Japan they
know what the Tennessee waltz is and
that's about it I don't even know what
that song is I figured out about it when
I was here yeah it's an oldie I think I
think their knowledge of the states yeah
so what is so six months in Japan have
you been having major culture shock what
do you like what don't you like has it
gone it has been pretty good so far the
culture shock isn't as bad as I thought
it would be
that's pretty global lightest world at
this point so you know what Japan is
like difference wise so it's been pretty
good so far the biggest difference has
been the academic system so it's pretty
fundamentally different from American
conceptions of Education yes so that's
one thing yeah and that's one of the
things that you had written in that you
wanted to talk about a little bit about
academia and the difference between
America and Japan so let's let's do that
all right so it's just essentially been
really refreshing being here because a
lot of the more annoying aspects of
American academia are not present here
at the moment they might be later on in
the future right so like what cancels so
like the big issue with academia right
now as you can imagine is the
ideological like constraints placed on
lots of students there but College in
Japan is not a very ideological place
like the classroom is a sacred
environment you do not talk about
ideological things there so it's pretty
much not an issue which has been really
good for me because that's one of the
reasons I wanted to come to Japan to
avoid that because my college is very
stereotypical very liberal and very free
speech sense there should be lots of
ways sure and a lot of the people that
I've been talking to you today are
mentioning things like that and we we
know about all this stuff so in Japan is
there a drawback to having sort of no
ideology in the classroom like is there
any kind of drawback to just sort of
straight information there's a bit of a
drawback Japan's academic structure has
its own issues that I could complain
about all day really of eight minutes I
know
but compared to the issues with America
right now I could deal with them way
more because that's essentially just me
saying why do I have to respect the
teacher all the time I'm American I
don't respect people
so that's really the main issue but like
information being presented here just so
straightforwardly
really does seem to help like nip the
ideological issues in the bud there
because that's not something teachers
are supposed to be doing yeah so how is
it for you you said you've been there
for six months being an outsider in a
pretty homogeneous society have you had
any challenges on that front um I
actually have nights it's pretty
interesting like people stare at you but
people stare anyone who is in Japanese
it's I think ninety-nine point seven
percent of the people here in Japanese
and like the points three people who are
left are mostly Korean and Chinese but
you're an oddity no matter what you look
like if you're from the West yeah do you
speak Japanese I speak Japanese
air-quote don't worry I'm not gonna test
you don't worry I started studying so I
am in no way fluent yeah but my speak to
prize people greatly yeah so one of the
things that you had written in that you
wanted to talk about that I thought was
really interesting was about content
creators being unfairly criticized and I
think what you were referring to is
generally just sort of these youtubers
that put their thoughts out there that
end up getting trolled endlessly that's
the sense that I got am I am I right on
that and if not please correct me oh
yeah there's that there's the broader
sense of content creation where it's
like there are people who are writing
books or making comics or movies that
are being endlessly criticized at the
very ideological banks at this point
mm-hmm to the point where not meeting
certain very leftist standards is
considered a drawback in a false when it
probably shouldn't inherently be yeah so
give me an example of that so it's like
it's not like I am mad when women show
up in comic books but I don't think it's
all that fair when you get comic books
pulled because they don't have women in
them like that's not a drawback
yeah so that is the car see many years
ago now because I'm old with the Joker
comic book cover where the Joker was
abusing Batgirl because the Joker is the
Joker but they had that comic book cover
pulled and the artist essentially
blacklisted because they said it
encouraged violence against women and
that should not have happened
the Joker was a bad guy that's what bad
guys do yeah a lot of people seem to
really mix up what characters do versus
what the author does so it's the George
Lucas argument where it's just like he
put Leah and her skimpy outfits like
Jabba the Hutt foot Leia and a skimpy
outfit cuz job and I hunts is a bad guy
and you're supposed to think he's creepy
yeah do you find that fascinating
yeah I mean I I find that totally
fascinating that people seem incapable a
certain amount of people are incapable
of separating the artist the creator
George Lucas who draws you know comes up
with the idea of Jabba and then he had
it he had a slave and he put her in a
sexy outfit and people think that's him
imposing his view on what he thinks
women should be it's kind of crazy yeah
it's pretty ridiculous I don't want
George Lucas nice you've done very
objectionable things on other things
Jar Jar is that a Jar Jar knock that's
it's a knock against many many aspects
of the Star Wars well not this lightly a
thing it is fine yeah you know that Star
Wars is like everything to me I mean I
don't know what to say right now I'm
sure you would agree with me on many of
my complaints